ice ice baby before we go here's one
thing you can do today to live a happier
healthier and more productive life
that's the name that song I think no
that's under pressure I think oh it's
under pressure some of those baby it's
part of our partnership Thank You
Anthony Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcasts happier happier
more than 115 million Americans will
travel during this holiday season
according to triple-a I like how you
said no that's actually under pressure
ports can be exhausting and Families
experience more holiday stress traveling
with your children
happiness expert in New York Times
bestselling author Gretchen Rubin is
here with tips to make your holiday trip
a little less stressful number one I
like that your title is a happiness
expert so madam happiness expert how can
families prepare getting on getting
ready to travel with the family well the
first thing is the most obvious which is
give yourself a lot of time each person
in a group adds time children add more
time give yourself plenty of time also
don't let yourself fall into empty keep
you know go into empty
Bollin tempting keep cash in your wallet
oh gas in your car keep snacks in the
bag keep your phone get organized before
you go so that it's easier when you come
back and also you know sometimes we want
to eke out every possible minute and you
come back Sunday night and then
everything starts again on Monday if you
can give yourself a little buffer I read
your holiday book so when you finally do
get on the road you're in transit
difficult time when you have kids aside
from just putting on a video in the
backseat what can you do to get through
it well I live a fun bag where you give
them a bagger like a little backpack and
all those little things you know that
you get in gift bags over the years the
little figurines the little travel games
stick it in there never let them play
with the stuff unless they're actually
traveling and you can keep a little kid
occupied for a long time with just a
bunch of little things you say we
shouldn't over booked our holiday
vacations yes it's so easy to get too
much we get overextended we're exhausted
our little kids are exhausted or older
parents and relatives are exhausted if
you've got a partner it can be really
nice to say I'll spell you for a while
you get a
break then I get a break let's let's
pace ourselves and you know there are a
lot of demands on your time everybody
wants to see you how do you say no to
friends and family who are inviting you
to come so the keys don't over explain
that's how you get into her don't
justify just say that doesn't work for
us yes and it's like that it's also
helpful if you lead with a warm touch
like we can't wait to see you this is
gonna be great but that doesn't work for
us how about Brian that's so friendly
that doesn't work yes no was a complete
sentence I've learned but I always feel
you have to offer an explanation we have
a better off doesn't work and you know
maybe you can say offer an alternative
or you can stall and just say we're
still working on some of the plans for
the day but we'll get back to you how do
you keep from getting overwhelmed by it
all well you know part of it is just
stay focused on what you're there for
which is relationships you know you get
so swept up with the errands and the
relationships and just say we're here to
have fun together like maybe you want to
start a new tradition which is kind of
an oxymoron but like we're gonna start
doing puzzles we're gonna yeah we're
gonna take a walk we're gonna have a
conversation we're really gonna stay out
of empty Diana no I like that I don't
and I like that doesn't work for us
[Laughter]
that'll do is we will see you tomorrow I
hope this works for you tomorrow and she
gives this morning take it easy